Speaking of Donald Trump at Davos, Donald
Trump has targeted a 17 year old kid in a
completely incoherent tirade at the Davos
world economic forum in Switzerland. I happen
to be talking about 17 year old Swedish climate
activists, Gretta Toon Berg, Donald Trump
included in his screed that she quote, barely
beat him out to be on the cover of time magazine.
The president of the United States, a 73 year
old billionaire is attacking a 17 year old
autistic kid who just wants to save the planet.
This is where we are in 2020 it's sick, it's
disgusting, but we're sort of used to the
fact that this is where we are and the reality
is it's going to continue if an until this
guy is removed in November of 2020 ultimately
leaving office in January of 2021 Donald Trump
also may be even more disturbingly said that
Gretta, Toon Berg should really focus on the
pollution of other countries because the United
States is doing fine, which is a crazy thing
to say. Let's take a look at the clip and
then discuss.
You're doing a no. How old were you? How old
is she? She's a 17. Yes. That's, what is your
response to beat me out on time magazine?
What did you hear from other world leaders
and business leaders who said, no, I did was
actually what? I would have loved to have
seen her speak. Uh, I did not know and got
it all. I think what is, I think aspects of
it are, uh, I think that some people are,
they put it at a level that is, you know,
unrealistic to a point. You can't live your
lives. We want to have the cleanest water
on earth. We want to have the cleanest air
on earth. Our numbers, as you saw, we had
record numbers come out very recently. Our
numbers are very, very good. Our environmental
numbers, our water numbers are, our numbers
on air are tremendous.
We have to do something about other continents.
We have to do something about other countries.
Uh, when we're clean and beautiful and everything's
good. But you have another continent where
the fumes arising at levels that you can't
believe. I mean, I think Gretta autofocus
or those places, but we are doing better right
now than we've ever done in terms of cleanliness,
in terms of numbers. We have a beautiful ocean
called the Pacific ocean with thousands and
thousands of tons of garbage flows toward
us and that's what they are by other countries.
So I think Gretta has to start working on
those other countries.
So just the fact that he's attacking a kid
is insane that he's obsessed with Gretta Toon
Berg. It's very, very weird and in fact, I've
previously spoken about how it's bizarre how
easily and totally triggered the right is
by Gretta Toon Berg. It's not just Trump,
it's a kid who wants to save the planet and
who speaks in a way that inspires a lot of
people to take seriously this issue of the
climate and pollution and climate change.
And so many Republicans are just so instantly
triggered by Gretta tune Burg. But then Donald
Trump said the U S is clean and beautiful
and Gretta should be focusing elsewhere. That's
wrong. The United States is a huge disproportionate
polluter and user of fossil fuels on a per
capita basis. It's the opposite of what Donald
Trump says. In reality, there are many countries
that pollute the United States on a per capita
basis, disproportionately does so, but it
shouldn't really come as a surprise that Donald
Trump is spreading misinformation on this
issue because he did say climate change is
a hoax created by the Chinese to bolster their
manufacturing industry.
Trump lost out to a teenager who wants to
save the planet for being on the cover of
time magazine and he's furious and he's taking
it out of her nice little presidency we have
here. Not embarrassing at all. And then I
remembered Melania Trump, Donald Trump's wife.
One of her issues was being against bullying
when she was asked what are, what are the
key issues going to be? Michelle Obama nutrition
and the white house garden and vegetables
and you know, was one a very prominent issue
for Michelle Obama for a millennia it was
going to be bullying. She doesn't like bullying.
Her husband is bullying a child. Her husband
is pulling a child who's doing something good.
I think it's important to add, but don't even
dare mention Baron Trump's name by the way.
That would be completely and totally off limits
even saying his name is not allowed.
The reality around the world at a global level
is that this 17 year old kid, 17 year old
grad attuned Berg at the global level is more
respected than Donald Trump and Trump on some
level probably perceives that people react
more positively to Gretta Toon Berg than to
him when she walks in the room compared to
when he walks in the room. Unless it's a handpicked
crowd at a sycophantic rally and he can't
take it and he's attacking a kid again, it's
truly incredible.